皆さんは消しゴムご存知でしょうか消しば無敵声が小さいイメージがあるんですけども
世の中にはでかい木熟も味まして僕がネットで探すところ一番でちゃって消しゴムを
買ってきました
こちら
pou dou dou
a かヤンマーこれベイダー s 1万円という基準ですねえっさーちゃんと記事ゴム
ですねー
まって本当は凍っあの分かります財布がこれ消しゴムなんてでもちょっとこれ本ステ
やばいよ
ちなみにこの下時5分10000円です
とりあえずと何キロあるだけ飾ってみましょうやばいばちゃんと記事ボムだ
普通に実用性の普通にあがこのつくのような最初はサイズをやばいぞ分
2.1キロというわけで今日やりたいとか皆さん家集合まで消しカス
こうやってンって言ってね歴史をつくっていませんでしたらあの北小学校ん時はねって
くださいめっちゃやってて夢だったんですよ
例会ね下条作るのこんなでかい手島るっていう事を知らなかったんで今日はこの2 k
ん歩け自分を使って練り消しをつくってみたいと思いますこんだけ次回語ろう
本当に見たことのないでくれとねりけしができると思うんで果たしてネギラーの景色も
使えばどれからねりけしができるでしょうか
フェアがーかもよでは作っていきましょう
でかいなただ俺小学の時作って限界の大きさはこれくらいだったんですよ俺がはるかに
上回る出来がおつくったらもう小学校でモテること間違いなし
あってもあちゃんとできるちゃんができるちゃんとできるサンプル分かりますこのこれ
この絶海ヒモっぽいこれこれが出るフェスの元なんですね
おろし一家にかき集めれば練り傷ができるわけでございますよ
あと4ヶ月はかかりそうですね
[音楽]
ああああああ
ています
こんな感じですね今なんかただの薄汚いごめんに見えますがこれをこの両八重歯も
すごいと思うんで早速やってみましょう
[音楽]
なぜ本当にこれ待って本当にええに終わる可能性あるん
ふーん
すなう
[音楽]
ピンチだなぁ
かなりピンク f
はランそこでは
ben
福所
ま無理な直接これ日からおかげでも出る気しないくらいかかるんだよなポイントただけ
負ければきっともこれ自体を練り消しになるそうだろう相棒
展開ますはいというスノキ打っていいんですけども団地とヒット膜面似せようとしても
ちょっと自分影さなんであれ前の傷に終わった後にそれなら光モールなりなんとかして
はんぺんフェスを作ろうと思いますそれぞれ
競馬わー
ちょっとツアーなこの曲も30分くらいそんなんだってこのレベルなカードがちょっと
だけ丸くだったレベルなんでこれ多分
12ちゃってもこれ終わらないんですよねこれこれちょっと撮影なんか動物からダメだ
と思うんで
なんか探してきます
[音楽]
さぁづ埋めてまいりましたもうてやってでもまず版者はないんでなんか自分が買ってき
ましたベルトディスクサンダー
a 覚えやばい一応2万円ばさらに自動やってるみたいな感じですねこれやめたらまず
で my これ
消しゴム多分これとか一瞬で無くなるレベル4と思います
おおこれはヤバイマジでやっとリビシこれはやばい立ってみてくださいここ
でる奴になっててこれが改定すると多分女にかやばかった視力お店で見たときいきます
えっさー
ore
[音楽]
[拍手]
おっちぼっちっが摩擦で3月で消しゴムの小江戸がめっちゃを使ったっ
敦獲びっくりされますすごいなこれ
[音楽]
はっはっは
ばいいんだよ惚れちゃったーーーーうす型 s e キャブそれはまだちょっといい
感じになったばっかフェア本プレーンな始まってそのせいかられます
[音楽]
[拍手]
よしここで削りましょう
壊れましたここで削れます
[音楽]
すごい溶けてるご覧ください何か他の摩擦であったら詐欺て一種のスーッと消しか
すごい
こんなにはっきりとける画像やは頑張ろう
これはもう最初あんなに全体奴がもうほぼ一緒ぐらいまできました
減ってるジャケッツますけどやっぱりなかなか願いですね
[音楽]
ん
ザックってパック設定パッ
[音楽]
ん
えっ
[音楽]
ねっ
えっ
はいやばいはが降ったからずっとはまずれないんだよ
マイカーのすごいんですよ擦って擦ってこうすればで打った結果凄いことになっちゃい
ました
骨が消しゴムんですよどう思います何かもうブルーブルーブルーするんですよねこんな
ことになるとは思うないっすよねちょっと硬いそれでこのこれがコネが足りないような
気がしますねこれはもう
黒これをこれから練って練り消しにするわけなんですけどもハブなんですけどやさっき
ネットで調べたところから撮り方そういいね力士になるみたいなことも書いてあったん
ででもこれに取りたしてちょっとこでこにすれば最強そうね力士ができると思うので味
とやっていきましょう
津波にもう7時間あたっておりますしてみたいあー
ピッチャー今やソーダの準備しましたもう下敷きの最高はレベルだと思ってくれ
当然はもうすぐできるんじゃないかっていう
[音楽]
山でランランなどねボロボロなんだけどずっと
グリマーこんなことないじゃ
[音楽]
ガー皆様役で歴史のするでがわかったよ色々あって化粧がこうなっちゃったんだけども
そのままですよ女力士はで気軽でどうしようかと言いますとね歴史にしやすい犬種もと
しにくい化粧があるんですよね水消しゴムっていくも音がモチモチというか
伸びのあるマット丸文とかそうですねあれはすごいでれ希少作りやすい犬種 com で
それいた
してこんなに使ってるほど記事昆布はめちゃくちゃ大きかったんですけどもうちょっと
硬くて午後してどっちかというとねりけし向きではないな街こうやって活動を超えて
子猫にせてもまとまらなくて一生を抜いてしまう作れまあ
というわけでどうすればいいかと言いますと話し調べたところなんか水の利率の良いで
とすごいいいらしい
そして私はひらめいてしまいましたまずで消し方がめっちゃ解けたんですよつない決勝
がって熱で溶けることがわかったのでもう1回ネックを当てれば消しゴム解け待って
解けた消しゴムの中にアラビックヤマトとかの水糊を貸して混ぜればそれでエネルギー
が完成する
じゃないかと
私は値引きして呼んでいいのかねって良いないんですけども完全に抜け失敗
完全ケースができると思うんで方せっかく
でもこうしないとフライバーに生えないから正解かんフライパンで入るように出来た
この消しゴム等を1回畑食べますじゃあん
というわけですごい番組で温めてきますこんな邪道のやり方でどうかと思う人もいると
思うんですけども
根岸ができればそれでいいんですねってないけどスーツこれを温めてみましょういって
いきますよろしくお願います
[音楽]
降ってきてきて来い答えがいっぱいえっ
い
何がどうやって黄色くなったよああ怖いけどため成功ですこれ
雑感といけません
なんかねえこれでいいのかなぁ通常よくわかんないですけどそれぞれもう乗り混ぜます
抜け主催できればいいんで僕は混ぜます
なんか料理してるみたいな
[音楽]
もう一回行ってきますではそのんだ
いろいろ試してみたんですけどもん
無理かもしれないと思ってきますね原図をこんな感じですねから一部を取り出して電子
ネジで注意してみたんですけども
だからキー6取っちゃうんですよねこれねやってこれ大丈夫か
一応これ水なりだした状態で食べたんですけども一部だけとけっ
無理だわ水のに出してもこのレベルなぜね結局は一応方ずにはなったものの仲値れる
化粧には到底なれないみたいな感じだと思いますでこれ何でかと言いますと色々調べた
んですけども
とりあえず電子レンジでチンしても消しゴムアナがあまり解けないらしいですねそこに
水成田してもできないってものがネットに書いてありますが既に調査済みらしいですで
さらに言うとも本当に記事ゴムの
声質で決まるらしくて今回使ったのめちゃくちゃでかい2キロの岸ゴムを見るからに
無理をなんかどんなコネでもこれでもずっとぽろぽろぽろぽろすーしー見るのに対して
も全然変わんないし電子レンジでチンしてもなんか
こんななっちゃうし
これのが館返して
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
バッハ